[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and i'm
out here at ces 2017 and i guess
mercedes saw what i was doing with all
the other car videos with tesla so they
invited me out to the desert to take a
look at the way they're attacking
self-driving so obviously a lot of
people know about tesla and their
self-driving capabilities it's
practically what they're most known for
but a lot of people forget or don't even
realize a lot of other car manufacturers
are working on the same thing in their
own way so you're probably already
familiar with mercedes and their great
reputation for you know quality and
luxury and their interiors you've seen
them before but what they did here uh is
they took a production e-class that
you've already seen it's on the road but
they outfitted and upgraded the interior
with additional features and there's
other sensors for what they call drive
pilot so that's coming in s-class later
in 2017 so this isn't even out yet so
yeah the car you're looking at is a bit
of a frankenstein mobile with a black
box in the trunk not the prettiest thing
in the world but hey it's a demo of the
self-driving tech and that's what
they're working on they're going to be
putting it in cars pretty soon so you
can see where they've put the sensors
they have the dual camera system all the
way up at the front just like the tesla
it's reading street signs and speed
limits and things like that and then
there's also radar firing from behind
bumpers on both the left and right hand
side to see around the car and what's
near you on the road and even a
forward-facing radar to bounce off the
car in front of you that's coming from
literally behind the mercedes logo so i
got a little demo walkthrough from the
mercedes guys as they went through it
basically they showed me all the
features and walked me through it and i
was comparing it in my mind to the way
tesla does it and then i was able to get
in the driver's seat myself and check it
out and i basically found i'd say two
main differences versus the tesla
autopilot so the biggest difference is
basically they're not using just the
sensors and the cameras in the car for
autonomous driving like tesla does
they're actually adding map data from a
company called here maps as well to
augment that so it's not just the
sensors and the cameras it's the sensors
and the cameras and maps so basically in
regular driving and normal roads that
doesn't matter too much but it does add
the ability to make a turn by itself
when it's on the map so for example if
i'm on a road and the car is
self-driving and my turn is coming up
you know a couple hundred yards before
my turn i'll put the blinker on so the
car keeps driving but when i do that it
checks the map to see when the next turn
is when you get close to it it'll slow
you down automatically make the turn for
you and then accelerate back up to the
speed limit so that was pretty cool to
see in action uh and then the other
thing is you know tesla model s is
already level two self-driving so lane
assist and adaptive cruise control
combine but there are a little more
lacks about keeping your hands on the
wheel like i'm used to reminding me
maybe every 30 seconds or so depending
on the roads to you know get your hands
back on the wheel pay attention just
touch it to confirm you're still here
but that makes sense in a level two
system the mercedes system drive pilot
is a little more about like keeping your
hands on the wheel to be ready to take
control back even when the car is still
doing the steering so they put all the
controls on the steering wheel itself
instead of on a separate stock so you
can control everything about the
self-driving and the speed control and
navigation everything without taking
your hands off the wheel and the system
also asks you to confirm you're paying
attention maybe every 10 seconds or so
it felt like which could feel kind of
annoying if you're feeling lazy but they
kept it easier with this little touch
pad on either side of the steering wheel
so you just basically touch it to
confirm you're paying attention so you
don't really have to grip the steering
wheel like you do on the tesla you just
touch either side of the steering wheel
on the little pad and the warning on the
dashboard goes away
but that's the main difference that's
what differentiates it from what i've
used it doesn't take me that long to get
used to it i got comfortable pretty
quick and i trusted it on these roads i
mean obviously i've used a car with
autopilot before so wasn't that crazy
but the handling of turns was a nice
little additional feature to have thanks
to the map data the hard part though is
gps isn't perfect like maps aren't even
perfect we all know we've all seen apple
maps i even tried uh putting the blinker
on near the end of my drive to make a
right-hand turn but that road actually
wasn't on the map
so it just left the right blinker on and
kept going it wasn't going to slow down
so i ended up having to take control hit
the brake and make the turn myself so it
doesn't seem like a big deal you know
it's the little things you can still do
that it's clearly still evolving it's
level two not level five but the
question i have is will people trust it
like would you trust it obviously tech
enthusiasts like me who trust computers
are totally fine with it but uh let me
know what you think what do you think of
self-driving thanks for watching this
one and i'll talk to you guys the next
one peace
[Music]